et pour évoquer la situation en côte
d'ivoire avec nous en direct jean bonnan
il est vice-président bief pays le front
populaire et voile jean monnet bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors pourquoi parce que la fing et soit
attendu pour rejoindre l'appel lancé par
henri konan-bédié parce que la ping et
ça a été le premier à lancer
rassemblement de toute l'opposition
ivoirienne ou faire barrage à la
dictature de monsieur ouattara et à son
régime
donc suite à ces appels au rassemblement
qu'il a lancé le bassin groupe
mais c'est vrai qu'on a un bédié a lancé
dans l'idée de la désobéissance civile à
laquelle monsieur pascal affi n'guessan
et de nombreux leaders politiques de
l'opposition ont souscrit alors je
voudrais savoir vous êtes vice-président
du fps qu'aujourd'hui tout le fbi la
totalité du front populaire ivoirien est
derrière pascal affi n'guessan on sait
qu'une a pour qui le candidat du fpr
doit être laurent gbagbo laurent gbagbo
sinon rien non aujourd'hui tout le pays
est favorable à une action concertée de
sorte que ensemble nous mettions nos
querelles intestines en veilleuse parce
que aujourd'hui il s'agit de l'intérêt
national de l'intérêt général et quand
l'intérêt national prime sur toute autre
considération partisane
donc on peut considérer que aujourd'hui
c'est tout le fric est là à la
désobéissance civile
est-ce que l'opposition ivoirienne fera
front commun contre alassane ouattara je
parle peut-être d'une et unique
candidature de l'opposition
il n'avait pas question le mandat des
passes il est par exemple est parfois
réduit
ce n'est pas exclu mais pour moi le plus
important pour nous c'est de nouvel
ensemble en ordre de bataille pour
obtenir des élections transparentes
crédibles et inclusive
ps ans sybille concrètement ça veut dire
quoi dans les jours à venir
les leaders donc le brut sur hbo serait
rudy donner un contenu concret à cette
désobéissance civile alors pascal affi
n'guessan n'guessan avait déjà dit il
pourrait retirer sa candidature s'il
estime que l'élection présidentielle
reste toujours frauduleux en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il pense
est ce que c'est encore d'actualité est
ce qu'il pourrait se retirer de la
course à la présidentielle mais
implicitement oui puisque hull il a dit
qu'il n'irait pas à une élection plus
que la bosse à une élection d'or les
organisateurs n'essayez pas pour pierre
donc aux candidats jean bonard merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes vice
président du fpi
le front populaire ivoirien merci